I was wondering if we could start by you
painting a picture of the schedule for
this because I know what this was in
pre-production breathe happens so what
exactly were you working on and when
that's right I mean yes absolutely this
so this film has has been evolving over
four plus years and and I was involved
pretty much from the beginning so yeah
we had a kind of slight diversion with
breathe which is a film starring Andrew
Garfield and Claire Foy and which also
scored and and and that was very
interesting cuz it was total departure
from this universe that we were
occupying but I guess it's just kind of
it over time and actually in some ways I
think the fact that we had a lot of time
to literally take a breather from it you
know was was really good because it gave
us some perspective into and so I think
that really helped because at times you
know we come back and go actually that
particular theme or that feeling you
know maybe we can make more of that or
maybe we could take it a different
direction now so I think it was great to
have that much time to play with and
real kind of I mean a rare luxury to be
honest what was your first reaction when
Andy came to you with this project
because whenever you hear an adaptation
of any kind of classic source material I
imagine it must be intimidating while
also being exciting it was very exciting
and it was intimidating but it was also
you know I was very excited by the fact
that he was going back to the original
source material and so it was a chance
to to really explore everything away
from the association of Disney which I
love I mean everyone loves the Louie
prima songs and loves that original kind
of cartoon but it's it was great to kind
of really explore a universe of in a
fresh way and yeah I think yeah I mean
from the beginning it would just felt
like a great experience and it's it
continued to be during the course of it
did you have any specific influences
that kind of shaped what you were doing
on this because I'm I'm a big horror
genre lover there are some really deep
tones and this that yeah they're
chilling yeah I mean I'm big horror love
it as well but I think it wasn't I
wasn't consciously thinking that way I
think the material the original material
is it's very dark and that's that's why
I think some people find it confusing
but if you think about Andy and the kind
of movies he's associated with
with Lord of the Rings or Planet of the
Apes and so on it's not a kind it's not
the kind of movie you shouldn't expect
from Andy but but I also think it can be
tricky for people to accept a very
different kind telling of the story they
kind of know that's understandable but I
feel like we're in an age where there's
so many adaptations and different
interpretations and it winds up just
spreading the love for something that
maybe someone wasn't exposed well I
loved it I mean I loved kind of getting
into the darkness of chacon and getting
into this universe which felt savage and
brutal and visceral and kind of real and
and you know the feeling is I mean you
quite a few times you're jumping out of
your skin because you kind of terrified
for Mowgli and you should be you're in
the jungle with the kid who's kind of
expose the elements enter - and caught
between two worlds the world of men and
and animals and and to try to capture
that you know it couldn't be a pretty
fight kind of score you know I mean and
he got really into the heart of the
material and I think you know that's
what I loved about his work I mean he
wants things to be authentic and also
there was an opportunity to bring in
Indian classical influences and so on um
you know writing the song for example I
also thought it'd be important to keep
it in the same universe because that
comes up in the end credits and so for
me it was it was important that we don't
break that spell because he creates a
spell during the course of this which is
very powerful and quite often I'll go to
see movies and I'll think what's that
song got to do what I've just watched
and and so for me I used the same melody
a lot of the influences are the same
instrumentation and a great singer
called car Imani who this voice is quite
epic and quite powerful but she's only
20 years old and so it was important to
me to kind of really keep us in the
universe of this film all the way
through to the last moment of the
credits to wrap this up now I love
hearing about I guess kind of the
some hero of them would be because so
many people are involved in making every
single movie so from your specific
Department if you want someone's work to
be out there and someone to know
someone's name who would you pick Wow
sure I'm sure there are many people but
yeah I think to be answered though there
were so many stars of the film in terms
of all of the work that was done but but
I guess for me it would be I mean that's
really difficult I'd say I would say
karmani who actually sung the song just
because she's she's a young person who
had to jump in from scratch and she had
to really try to capture a feeling and
really kind of own you know a whole
theme that I'd kind of evolved over
years and she had to make it feel like
it was her own so yeah I mean ironically
the unsung hero is the singer let's see
[Music]
you